small disclaimer this is part two of a
two-part series if you wish to see part
1 the video is in the description down
below please enjoy the video number 3
dude I still think this should be higher
and you're entitled to you of every
wrong opinion huh Who am I kidding I'm
just happy I get to talk about this one
this sequence is not only a fantastic
piece of animation but is by far my
favorite part of the entire tournament
made possible by two spectacularly
talented individuals Kenta Ukiah and the
man who needs no introduction mr. Yuya
Takahashi Yuya Takahashi's impact on
Dragon Ball super our work has been
almost as enormous as your mom the sheer
quazy that this man can produce in such
a short time is only one of many things
that should tell you this man is a
master of his craft before I get into
explaining how the best you got
Takahashi and Kenta your coil war here I
want to draw attention to this scene and
this episode's strongest attribute
Megumi a sheet on EES storyboard if you
think Takahashi is a prodigy a sheet ani
graduated college in get this 2015 she's
younger than me she joined Dragon Ball
super in 2016 and in the span of less
than two years managed to convince those
working in toey that she was the woman
who was to direct the last episode in
one of the most popular series in the
world coming out of Japan that sort of
stuff doesn't happen ever
so mokuba ash-shaytani thank you for
helping make this episode and seen as
fantastic as it was regarding this entry
scene it is one minute 13 seconds long
with one minute provided by takahashi
not to discredit coiours contribution i
absolutely loved it especially that
sideview tracking shot as Goku and
Frieza run along the floor of the arena
completement Frieza Naruto run however
regarding takahashi while his animated
contributions have been solid those fire
in this series nothing quite compares to
this magnificent effort in the final
episode I would like to add perspective
to this if I can working on the final
episode of a tournament can be
overwhelming the pressure is there to
not only finish strong but with
something
and if anything was off you know the
world would let them know but it's in
this moment that takahashi delivers his
best work on the series packing with
snappy movements and cool effects
alongside all that it also is sprinkled
with little subtle touches of brilliance
it's easy to get on my good side with
wonderful expressions but genuinely this
cut is filled with such a refreshing
intensity earning its spot as our number
3 number 2 now key today is a name that
deserves endless amounts of praise for
his contributions on the series for
having unfortunately had his name
attached to episode 5 along with a
naturally low detail and loose style
it's been very hard to convince people
unfamiliar with his work he's actually
one of toei's best well I think the
scene absolutely does him justice with
him an amazing ultra instincts debut and
frankly defining that forms movement as
a whole opening with remarkably delicate
footwork Tati brings Goku snapping
forwards into jaren before executing a
perfect rotation there are lovely plumes
of smokers jaren very literally snaps in
front of Goku who's already managed to
dodge the attack hitting the ground we
get some interesting character acting as
Goku examines his new form before topo
and dispo comes zooming down the
mountain and lunge at Goku grabbing them
toss a really sums up Ultra instincts
movement by having Goku's arms relaxed
for the twist before stiffening them
instantly for one hell of a throw this
scene wraps up with effects porn heaven
as toppers beam explodes in the
background and Tati animates one of the
coolest comest and most intense walks in
the series effortlessly brushing aside a
straight beam this is animation at its
purest form characterizing an entire
transformation without a single word
being uttered thanks to one hell of a
schedule it took a while for Tati to be
given the chance to prove himself again
but he really pulled it off and this
sits rightfully in spot number two
number one I don't think there was any
doubt as to what would top this list and
that is for good reason the absurd
amount of effort on display here is
nothing short of incredible from toys in
house staff will
no outside help it cannot be understated
how utterly triumphant episode 130 was
not only was it the most animated
episode in all of Dragon Ball super
archive but it was by a wide margin the
most well animated episode Dragon Ball
has ever seen through its various
televised incarnations and looking at
the staff list for this episode it's
easy to see why from Tata to Munnabhai
to Higa she'd a to know Toshi Sheeta
from top to bottom we have almost every
major top level action animator
available to tobe working on this
episode Tasi kicks off the episode as
Goku flashes past jaren everything feels
so so fluid and smooth which works
wonderfully well with a form like ultra
instinct as we said earlier his cut is
full of personality squash and stretch
dramatic zooms in zooms out as well as
tiny details that just adds the whole
experience the best way to describe his
work here is a vibrant and energetic it
is an exceptional opening immediately
following Tata we are hit by Nick I
chose work and I say hit because wow
this exciting scene features incredibly
well timed back handsprings
trailed by sharp red blasts and various
plumes of smoke the effects work here is
stellar made even more evident when
jaren charges up a beam that looks as
though it was pulled straight from a
lava lamp very unique approach however
the most impressive part of Nick I chose
cut comes as he dashes towards the
camera as things get more heated between
Goku and jiren two young sir dashes into
the fray with a clash very reminiscent
of Dragon Ball Z's usual action style
couple that would choose exceptional
effects work as well as some brat
background animation and that concludes
the first half of the episode dude holy
that's just the first half okay
look AJ rest your voice I'll take it
from here
without even a chance to catch our
breath Kenji Buell launches us yet again
into more animation goodness by
producing probably his strongest
contribution to the series that's enough
to say his other stuff hasn't been
awesome but generally they have been
very effects focused stuff now again
that's not to say that this doesn't come
packed with impressive effects work of
course
does but we get to see some character
action too wonderful combat pieces nice
rotation and again some background
animation go super you're on a roll here
after that we the audience are finally
given a moment to catch our breath but
don't you dare think for a second that
means the great animation stops hell no
our man photos yoga she day makes his
fourth and final appearance on this list
in an extremely effective and visually
interesting cut as Goku and jairam
colored blue and red respectively
battle over a nostalgic backdrop it's an
amazing stylistic choice and one that
elevates the scene even further if that
were possible he continues animating
into the battle doing his awesome
Higashi day thing providing wonderful
unique effects and interesting impactful
movements as Goku runs and flips around
the arena dodging Juran's blasts ending
finally in this twisting twirling
flipping mega punch from Goku now I feel
what you're thinking we've peaked
there's no way that this could get any
better right enter now Toshi Tschida
everyone seems to be delivering their
a-game for this episode and Sheeta is no
different delivering his strongest cut
of animation for super it is packed to
bursting with his astounding
jaw-dropping character acting and Becks
work smooth hand-to-hand combat you name
it and it's there only about 47 seconds
in length this cut packs an incredible
amount of detail into its runtime nearly
every time you watch it you can see
something new and that's a great way of
describing this episode as a whole it is
jam-packed with so much detailed
movement expression and effects you
can't help but miss a lot while watching
even during this breakdown we didn't
cover everything
there's still Munnabhai and me yuma's
portions as well as I'm sure others this
episode really is the gift that keeps on
giving
it's easily the best animated episode
that Dragon Ball super has ever made and
it sits in a dominating fashion as our
number one they absolutely nailed it and
that's how you do a collab 100k
milestone special and finish a series
that I started back in the day
high-five yeah okay okay get out of my
house okay
hey guys special thanks to anime AJ for
helping me with this video and providing
all the information I went off of back
in all the earlier days his insight into
Dragon Balls
animation is unrivaled by anyone on this
platform and he's just such a nice young
man so I highly suggest you have a look
at his channel if you haven't already
subscribed I hear whisperings that he
might be covering the entire series of
super with his animation analysis as for
me this is a series i began back in the
day before I really knew anything about
animation since then I have been to
animation school and continued working
hard on my channel and I think it's very
representative of how far both this
video series and my channel have come
since I began making those videos back
in the day it seemed almost poetic that
I finished this series with the guy that
pretty much made this possible both of
us worked very hard on this so I hope it
lived up to your expectations these last
few weeks have been pretty insane thank
you all so much for believing in my
content and me thanks to you I've
achieved a goal I honestly never thought
would be possible
you really do inspire me to work harder
thank you guys so much for watching and
thank you all again for 100,000
subscribers I'm gonna be taking a small
vacation so there won't be any videos on
the channel for another two weeks but
when I return I have a very special
video planned look forward to that guys
but that'll do it for this week I've
been totally not mark thank you so much
for watching
you